stimmzettel gates in berlin es gibt
fehlende stimmzettel hier in der
hauptstadt das ist mittlerweile
bestätigt worden wir hören dass menschen
in ein bis zwei stunden noch einmal
wiederkommen wurden bei seiner sie
wurden weggeschickt von wahllokal
betroffenes wahllokal 405 in berlin das
hat keine zettel mehr und auch die
nachlieferung die geht nicht voran
aufgrund des smartphones also das ist
die des organisation über die wir genau
hier als hätten sie es gewusst von der
stunde gesprochen hatten mit julian
reichelt und mit hans ole jörges und
béla anda also diese desorganisation an
einem wochenende an dem berlin nicht nur
die wahl erlebt als wäre das nicht schon
genug sondern ein marathon eben sich
organisiert hat oder eben auch nicht
jetzt sind menschen offenbar gehindert
ihre stimme abzugeben auch wegen dieses
marathons es gibt stimmzettel knappheit
in berlin in diesem wahllokal und die
stimmzettel kommen nicht nach klaus weil
der marathon halt ist also das ist
natürlich ein typisches berlin phänomen
diese zusammenschau verschiedene
unverständlichkeit also so eine art
irrenhaus live business berlin das ganze
jahr über also wert absonderlich wenn es
und wunderlich wenn es nicht am wahltag
aus so wär wir müssen jetzt bei den
stimmzetteln bisschen gucken ob es ein
großes phänomen ist oder ein normales
denn es sind es hat aber bei jeder
bundestagswahl gibt es
unregelmäßigkeiten mit stimmzetteln
entscheidend ist dann ob es das ergebnis
in diesem wahlkreis beeinflusst hat oder
nicht dass muss angeguckt werden besser
wäre es anders und in berlin also der
kriege ich immer noch nicht mal ein
bisschen impuls weil es hätte mich
gewundert als eigentlich wäre eine
nachricht gewesen bei der wahl in berlin
ist alles glattgegangen das wäre
sozusagen die eigentlichen also wenn sie
klasse bis schon voll und ganz in berlin
angekommen
das illusion irrt
berlin ist die politik kurz vor schluss
rangekommen es gibt keine keinen zweiten
ort wo so schlecht regiert wird nichts
funktioniert wobei man die diagnose kann
wirklich sagen wir noch mal darauf
einzugehen man muss sich das natürlich
ganz genau anschauen den stimmzettel ist
ja vielleicht sozusagen das wort des
tages durch armin er ihr schon und wenn
quasi genau untersucht werden muss was
ich glaube ob armin laschet stimmzettel
gültigkeit hat oder ob er an regeln
übertreten hat mit konsequenzen dann
muss man natürlich wenn in dem wahllokal
wähler weg geschickt waren wir gar keine
stimmzettel mehr da sind mit genau so
großer aufmerksamkeit hinhocken
hingucken ich glaube halt in berlin wird
auch das nicht funktionieren die
aufklärung der welt am schluss sagen es
waren paare und leise nicht hat die
verwaltung so schlecht organisiert dass
es zehntausende von menschen gibt die
keinen gültigen personalausweis und kein
pass haben weil sie keinen termin bei
den bei den bürgerämtern kriegen um den
zu beantragen es gibt menschen die
können ihre kinder die gibt die geburts
geburt von kindern nicht anmelden weil
das der gleiche effekt ist das ist eine
und die die politik regiert einfach so
weiter es gab einmal eine note konferenz
über den zustand der verwaltung da
wusste man keine lösung und dann hat man
einfach weitergemacht und ich wundere
mich immer wieder dass in berlin die
parteien die dafür zuständig sind
verantwortlich sind weiter gewählt
furchtbares signal und es ist ja auch
wenn wir sagen heute ist sozusagen die
hoch-zeit der demokratie also der tag an
dem die bürger ihre mit gestaltungskraft
zu papier bringen können dann ist
natürlich jede einzelne stimme die durch
fehlerhafte
organisation nicht abgegeben werden kann
ein skandal jede einzelne stimme ist ein
skandal und wenn das viele sind und wenn
man überlegt dass viele leute vielleicht
noch gar nicht das wahllokal erreichen
konnten weil sie an irgendeiner marathon
überquerung nicht rüber kam dann ist es
schon knapp an einer situation wo man
sagen muss wie muss man sich ganz genau
anschauen ob dann in einigen
wahlbezirken das ergebnis überhaupt noch
das ergebnis ist was ist geworden wäre
ohne die beeinflussung ich kenne solche
bilder aus den anderen lehrern an
stundenlanges warten vor wahllokalen da
greifen wir uns hier an den kopf und den
armen margot glück dass wir in
deutschland anders organisiert sind dass
es anders läuft nein aber diese meldung
kommen jetzt hier mitten aus deutschland
aus berlin es geht um ein wahllokal in
charlottenburg wilmersdorf und während
wir hier drüber sprechen kommt die
zweite meldung aus dem anderen bezirk in
berlin da ist nämlich eine wartezeit
mittlerweile von über zwei stunden heißt
es in einem wahllokal in mitte grund der
marathon also auch da gibt es riesige
komplikationen wie ferdinand da unsere
wie viele leute werden darum drehe wir
kennen ja solche solche wahlzettel
geschichten sind ja üblicherweise in
anderen ländern manipulationen von
diktaturen oder halb diktaturen um eben
die stimmabgabe zu verhindern in
bestimmten regionen und oder
wahlbezirken oder wo die herrschende die
herrschende kraft verhindern will dass
sie abgewählt wähler findet also nicht
bloß in einer demokratie hat das schon
mal gegeben hätte gewählt haben und ich
hab nämlich erinnert jetzt hat mich
nicht ein ja ja doch es ist nämlich fand
gut dass ich finde gut dass klaus das so
differenziert darstellt und sagt das
muss aufgeklärt werden bei wartezeiten
hat es auch bei den kommunalwahlen in
niedersachsen gegeben vor zwei wochen
darstellen die leute stundenlang und
zwar wegen der korona maßnahmen vor den
wahllokalen zum teil ist aber was könnte
gerechnet und allein wer sie da auch
nach nach 18 uhr und die stimmen wurden
nicht mehr gezählt das ist natürlich
ganz fatal wenn das so ist aber daraus
sollte man lernen aber es ist natürlich
schlimm bei ich glaube in unseren köpfen
ist noch was anderes sie kennen ja aus
amerika nicht die die große diskussion
war die wahl rechtens oder nicht und
wenn man jetzt eine wahl hier hat die in
irgendeiner weise da zweifel aufrufen
lässt muss man sich zumindest sehr
intensiv damit befassen was ist da
schief gelaufen in den bezirken wie kann
man verhindern dass das ähnliche
diskussionen gibt wie wir sie in amerika
hat und selbst wenn es am ende alles
sauber sein sollte allein die tatsache
dass man den menschen erschüttert ist
nicht maximal leicht macht die stimme
abzugeben sondern es ihnen
verkompliziert das ist ein skandal an
sony ist ja ehrlich dass das dass eine
wahl ins trudeln kommen weil stimmzettel
fehlen das habe ich in meinem leben noch
nicht gehört und
das kann kann ich mir noch gar nicht
vorstellen in einem wahllokal in mitte
wo ich heute morgen wahlen wählen war
ist mir schon aufgefallen wir haben
jetzt mit vier oder fünf wahlzettel zu
tun ich habe sie jetzt nicht genau
gezählt aber die liegen darunter
verschiedene stapeln nebeneinander dass
jetzt eine wahlhelferin die also dann
mit den fingern jeweils einen zettel
oben wegnimmt und einem überreicht das
hoffentlich machen sie keine fehler und
überreichen nicht mal zwei von einem
stapel was schnell passiert ja wenn man
da ständig macht das war auch schon so
merkwürdig und es ist ein in der smart
dass man schuldige es macht man doch
vorher dass man die wahlzettel knickt
und in einen umschlag tut und dann den
menschen überreicht stadt dass da jemand
sitzt und greift sie von einem stapel
weg wo gibt's denn sowas und in seinem
wahlbezirk also aufs kleine
runtergebrochen sind ja 50 stimmen
unterschied schon was oder 70
jahrhundert wer dann sozusagen diesem
wahlkreis für sich entscheiden kann
insofern ist das schon etwas
aufmerksamkeit verdient und vielleicht
dass armin laschet heute gar nicht der
einzige der mit stimmen zeigen
[Musik]